alright last topic and we've touched on
this a few times but this is an example
of how difficult it is for businesses to
get their arms around this new reality
where we're living with Chris and it was
on Monday that the NFL identified the
rules for physicals and visits basically
no visits and the physicals will be
conducted by neutral outside physicians
for free agent acquisitions on Tuesday
they made it more clear and let's start
with free agents they can't announce
these deals any deal that hinges on a
player passing a physical they cannot
announce it at 4:00 p.m. Eastern today
that's that's when we're first going to
see the difference between this year and
other years right so far this year it's
been the same we're hearing about the
deals that are tentatively done but come
four o'clock Eastern there will not be
the announcements of deals being done
there will not be obviously press
conferences there can't be there won't
be conference calls these deals won't be
done for players who are required to
pass a physical and if you're making a
major financial investment they all have
to pass a physical right they're not
going to be announced until these
neutral outside doctors say ok deals
done and I think we're gonna see these
deals get finalized over the course of a
week to ten days given the arrangements
that are going to need to be made
so these players can get their physicals
Chris yeah no I think you're right it is
it's very odd you know into that you
know can you think of a player that's
been signed yet that even really has an
injury concern right I mean really I
mean I know all these guys are gonna get
physicals at some point but I think most
of the guys we've seen signed at this
point we haven't heard anything of like
ooh there's a little injury concerned
with this player and I think that's for
the reasons you're stating teams realize
like man it's just too risky right now
that's why we see the Jadeveon Clowney
z' of the world and other guys who have
a little bit of an injury history just
sitting there and that's what you know
you mentioned earlier the Cam Newton
situation is gonna be interesting going
forward because of this but yeah I think
the guys we've seen sign and major money
thrown to have a very clean injury
history you know like Jack Conklin he's
one I can think of the head of injury
all right he tore his ACL but tore his
ACL and a young part of his career and
has played good the last two years to
show
hey it's not an issue anymore and ACLS
don't necessarily scare teams like they
did you know 20 30 years ago so you know
I think that's a very real concern and I
think it's a really affects free agency
and where things go and how the money
gets spent teams might you know have to
sit back a little while and wait until
things get cleared up until they know
they can really you know do their due
diligence than some of these guys and I
think you've got two concerns here first
of all you've got the concern that a guy
who may have some sort of an injury
issue is not going to be flagged by a
doctor who isn't a team doctor right who
isn't versed in the kind of physical
exam that you need to impose on a
professional athlete this isn't an
annual checkup right this is can this
person go out and perform professional
athletics specifically football at the
highest possible level right the other
side of it too is you may get some
cowboy who decides hey I know what's
going on here and fail a guy right honey
they'll fail a guy who otherwise would
have passed over something that really
isn't a big deal but this person doesn't
know and this is my chance to step into
the big leagues and I'm gonna show these
people I know how to how to do a
physical on a professional athlete oh we
got a problem here oh we got a problem
here open got a problem there that could
happen to Chris yeah yeah I know you're
exactly right yeah that that's that's
scary I mean that really is and you know
again I don't know where it goes from
here but you know I just think of like
I'm trying to think of some other guys
that are out there like Melvin Gordon no
way he's getting signed anytime soon and
so they figure out medical issues and
what goes on from there I would think a
guy like Jason Peters and the
Philadelphia Eagles he's been heard a
lot over the last years and he's old
nobody's signing him until he can I
don't know if there's anybody else but
you're right that's that's really what
makes it you know weird to me the big
thing is to me Mike again with this
conversation you know let's just take it
back to Camden for a second if I'm in
Cam Newton's shoes I I'm going like I I
don't care I'm going screw you NFL
I'm calling the Bears is there a doctor
they like around the country that I can
go fly and see that they feel
comfortable with if he gives me the
proper update and I'm taking a private
plane and going to see them you know
it's my life this is what I do I play
football and if I had that kind of money
the Cam Newton does
and want to get a new start and get this
going I'm gonna take matters into my own
hands you know I'm gonna read be
respectful and not try to do anything
too crazy but gonna try to go to see a
doctor and and get this ball rolling and
get it going
and let me try to shape a little bit
what I think you're suggesting because I
think there's a way to do it without a
team being involved you just go back to
the doctor that has done the surgery on
your foot and you get a full and
complete evaluation from that doctor
right or go to some other doctor who
didn't do the surgery but who is someone
who has a good reputation right for that
kind of body part right that's what you
need to do but even then even then yeah
I know if Tina don't buy you that either
I don't know if they will the guy's just
trying to prop him up so he can get the
trade and so he can go get paid yeah and
they still are gonna want their guy to
look at the at the the the foot the
ankle the shoulder everything on Cam
Newton but you know trades are the issue
and that was another thing where the
guidance was provided yesterday by the
league not on Monday there was a
doughnut hole it was filled on Tuesday
and here's what the NFL said in the memo
that was sent to all teams and if our
players are prohibited from entering all
NFL Club facilities through March 31
2020 thereby preventing clubs from
administering physical exams to those
players acquired via a trade similar to
physical exams for free agents clubs may
opt to contact a physician to administer
the exam in the location of the players
residents so again you are delegating to
an outsider who you don't know who you
have no relationship with who as far as
you know has never done a physical
examination for an NFL athlete to find
out whether or not this is an
appropriate move and that's why Cam
Newton isn't going to get traded under
this procedure what about Trent Williams
right no one's willing to trade him
you're not gonna do it
you're not gonna do it until your people
can put their hands on the the the
player and figure out and you know
diagnosed with MRIs x-rays whatever and
figure out whether or not this guy is
ready to go and and and they say through
March 31 well is it going to be through
March 31 or is it gonna be through April
30 how long is this gonna last and and
there was a key line in this memo clubs
should consider
including contingency language and trade
agreements to account for a scenario
where a player is unable to take and
pass a physical by a date certain in
other words you put in the trade
agreement the trade documentation that
gets filed today at 4:00 p.m. Eastern
when the two teams say hey we've got a
trade that if the physical isn't passed
by April 15 the deal is off and you know
that could kill some of these deals and
we never which one it's gonna be yeah we
have to keep our eye on the possibility
one of these trades that's being done is
gonna blow up because a physical came
back negative when maybe the team doctor
would have said positive or a physical
can't be accomplished before the
deadline that the two sides have agreed
to yeah no I
it's crazy we're in crazy times and
we're just gonna see where it goes and
you know you and I'll be here to talk
about it when this stuff goes down but I
know that's the fascinating thing about
not only the world we're in right now
but as it pertains to the NFL let's
change that aspect and definitely gonna
make business harder for the NFL and
some of these teams and coaches and GM's
right now
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports